metro police with a message tonight for
all drivers to
slow down the number of deadly
hit-and-run cases on the rise in the
valley
they say each and every one could have
been prevented christian cazares joining
us live in studio with how you can play
a role in minimizing this growing
problem that's right brian while i sat
down with metro's traffic bureau today
about this ongoing issue they say the
concern
is the warmer weather and the
restriction rollbacks that could
help fuel the danger it's the right
thing to do
it's lawful you can save life by staying
on the scene
seconds matter there are mistakes fat
judgments or impairments that can change
your life
in seconds i've been told i was just
scared i've been told i don't have a
license
in some cases i thought i was at fault
when
me doing the investigation i'm the
investigator i know that person wasn't
at fault
so far this year deadly hit and runs are
on the rise
but it's hard to determine why the
hardest part according to lieutenant
greg munson
a life lost we have nine hit-and-run
fatalities so far this year
which is a lot higher than of course
last year at the same time
out of those nine we have four of them
that are solved
five that are unsolved two of them we do
have leads among those cases was this
scene saturday at charleston and rampart
a young woman killed as she crossed the
street the driver
didn't stop then they go home
[Music]
and they're scared they don't know what
to do and then we find them
and in this case this person he would
have been looking at
no violations really the guy didn't
really do anything wrong other than
he was driving down the road and
somebody jay walked out in front of him
now he's looking at serious felony
charges for
a what i call an accident the valley is
connected with state of the art
surveillance cameras that police say can
help trace these incidents
still the community is the best resource
if somebody comes to you and tells you
that i just hit somebody i think
you should absolutely step up and say
you need to go and turn yourself
in you need to call the police right now
well police say that decision of staying
or leaving an accident really does go
further than the criminal charges they
say
by staying on the scene and calling
police well the victims injured can get
immediate medical attention
which can ultimately save a life
christian casadas 8 news now